The Witcher 3 wild Hunt is still getting
new updates and CD projekt Red has
detailed what to expect when the next
major update arrives on December 14th
one of the big new features being added
is a photo mode which will let players
take photos and share them there will be
a photo mode contest to come later on
the studio set additionally there is a
new camera mode coming that moves the
camera closer to geralt players can mix
and match the camera setup for different
situations like exploring combat and
riding Roach The Witcher 3 is also
adding Ray tracing and ambient occlusion
on PC as well as an Ultra Plus setting
that introduces more details on
background characters and environmental
elements for PlayStation 5 and Xbox
series X and S players can look forward
to Performance and quality modes
additionally PS5 and Xbox series X
players will get ray tracing ambient
occlusion and other graphical features
these won't come to the less powerful
Series S but that system does have have
30 FPS and 60 FPS options to choose from
on PS5 The Witcher 3 will use the Dual
sense controller's haptic feedback and
adaptive triggers so players will feel
the action when they smack an enemy with
a sword or perform Magic on consoles
there will also be a new special mode
where players can hold down the left
trigger and use face buttons to cast
signs instead of needing to access the
radial menu each time there are a
variety of other quality of life
improvements coming with the update
including new walking and jogging
options for geralt and the ability to
change the size of the game's subtitles
cutscenes should be improved too to
address stuttering issues that could
appear additionally players can pause
the game's cutscenes with a new update
the full patch notes will be shared
closer to launch the developers said
teasing that there will be additional
surprises to come content inspired by
Netflix's which a TV show is also coming
to The Witcher 3 including swords based
on what Henry Cavill wielded during
season 1 and 2 what's more cross
progression is coming to The Witcher 3
so players can switch between platforms
more easily going forward
as for why CD projekt Red is continuing
to support The Witcher 3 in this way the
game has sold an astonishing 40 million
plus copies and it continues to be
popular thanks in part to the Netflix TV
series a fourth which a game is now in
development in addition to a remake of
the original Witcher the new update
arrives on December 14th alongside the
complete edition which includes the base
game all DLC and the two major
expansions hearts of stone and blood and
wine at launch the complete edition will
be digital only but a physical version
is coming later for anyone who already
owns The Witcher 3 wild Hunt on PS4 Xbox
One and PC they can get the next gen
upgrades for free what upgrades are you
looking forward to the most in the Next
Gen update for The Witcher 3 let us know
in the comments and we'll see you next
time on Gamespot news
foreign